most Rockets I think all Rockets have
multiple stages uh today uh maybe
they'll take us in the discussion of
what ideas that could be for single
stage uh to orbit Rockets but can you
describe this whole thing that you've
been mentioning here and there of
multiple stages of the rocket yeah no
that's a good question so ultimately you
know like I said you're kind of pushing
about 90 the Rockets like basically just
fuel with some skin on it you know what
I mean
um and so uh that skin weighs a lot of
you know skin and the engines do weigh a
lot you know like I said the the Falcon
99 zone is about 20 tons just the
boosters about 20 metric tons
um so it's not an insignificant amount
of weight so the idea is with staging is
you ditch anything you don't need more
or less so um in the you know Falcon 9
is a perfect rocket to think about this
because you have a upper stage and you
have a booster you know our first stage
and the first stage Burns through all
this fuel once it's out of fuel you let
go of the second stage and ta-da you
actually just basically started and lit
a brand new fresh rocket you know this
brand new fresh rocket now doesn't have
all that that 20 tons attached to it so
it's a lot lighter it doesn't need you
know it's nearly as many engines to push
it around it needs just one instead of
nine
um this engine can be optimized for the
vacuum of space as opposed to having to
operate at sea level with all of our
actually pretty thick atmosphere you
know relatively so there's so staging is
basically the idea that you get rid of
things you don't need on Earth again
kind of that whole like 10 percent
harder 10 easier if it was 10 easier
single stage door but would be no big
deal and it probably would have been
like the the way to get to orbit by
choice just because like it's not that
hard but with our Earth as it is uh with
physics as it is it's just
it's doable and we've had
and you know we almost kind of actually
the first orbit to take humans or the
first rocket to take humans into orbit
uh for from the United States
um which was the
Atlas rocket um was kind of a stage and
a half it actually only had like one big
fuel tank and what that is they actually
dropped off two of its three engines so
it just ditched some of the engines but
if it hadn't done that you know so kind
of people were like well that was single
stage it's like it still had a staging
event it still had a ditch mass in order
to even make it into orbit had it not
done that it would have not been able to
get into orbit so yeah you pretty
quickly look at your trade and say okay
well if I want to stick to single stage
to orbit my payload Mass becomes
tiny you know like you might be able to
put like you know a falcon 9 booster on
its own like if you just flew one of the
side core boosters of a falcon heavy
with a nose going on and everything just
said I'm just gonna fly this on its own
you might be able to put like a you know
10 kilograms into space or something you
know a very small amount we'll throw a
second stage on that thing and now you
can put uh you know 17
000 kilograms into space so it's just an
order you know orders of magnitude more
payload capacity because you did staging
because you ditched the vestigial weight
so
um the other thing that's uh hard about
that too uh is that the engines again
that operate at sea level uh are often
not great in in space and vice versa
like you physically can't almost
optimized for space engines you can't
even operate at sea level they'll
destroy themselves due to something
called flow separation so
um not only are you getting the benefit
of ditching all the weight but you're
also able to use a much more efficient
unless typically you know the much less
powerful engine in space